[Musique]
salut maronite les emmène aujourd'hui ça
lui alexandre pour cet épisode je te
prends pas découvert un dispositif
convivial et chaleureux le café des
aidants
bah oui alors allons-y mon cap si vous
aussi vous voulez découvrir ce moment
d'échangé convivial et chaleureux alors
suivez-moi
[Musique]
je vous retrouve à saint denis pour
assister à un café des aidants ce moment
de rencontre d'échangé et d'information
s'adresse à tous les jeunes en ligne
s'il est bien fait partie et elle va
nous raconter comment ce dispositif a
changé d'avis
bonjour sylvie journal owni nous sommes
ici où se déroule le café des aidants et
justement ma question est comment ce
dispositif va aider dans ton rôle au
quotidien cela m'a aidé à déculpabiliser
parce que quand on est une maman ou une
soeur des connaître quelqu'un on a
toujours l'impression qu'on n'en fait
pas assez
qu'est ce qui te plaît le plus justement
de ce café les aidants l'écoutent le
dialogue est ce que en dehors de ces une
cape et les aidants vous avez gardé des
liens entre vous tout à fait on se
téléphone on se rencontre on fait des
sorties ensemble ne fait beaucoup subi
mario
depuis 2014 les aidants réunionnais
peuvent participer à ces réunions tu as
place un travailleur social et un
psychologue répondent à leurs questions
c'est aussi le moment pour les
bénéficiaires de se renseigner sur les
différentes aides que propose le
département
bourgeois elle les gens maroni gaël
c'est quoi le café les aidant les café
des aidants sont des lieux des espaces
d'information d'échangés de rencontres
ils sont animés par un travailleur
social et un psychologue qui ont une
expertise sur la question des aidants il
dure 1h30 et se déroule dans un moment
convivial autour d'un thé ou d'un café
et de petits gâteaux le rôle du travail
anses sociale et d'apporter
l'information la plus juste et ramené de
la neutralité dans les propos tenus le
rôle du psychologue et de gérer un petit
peu la charge émotionnelle qui peut
découler quelquefois des échanges et qui
peut participer à secret d'état le café
des aidants est couvert à tous les
aidants c'est à dire à une personne qui
s'occupe d'une personne dépendante quel
que soit son âge ou sa pathologie cette
personne va lui apporter de l'aide et du
soutien au quotidien dans les actes de
la vie quotidienne pourquoi est il
important d'avoir un lieu des changes et
des côtes précise et d'enregistrement
c'est important puisque le café des
aidants est un dispositif qui vise à
prévenir l'épuisement des aidants qui va
leur permettre de rompre leur isolement
d'aller à la rencontre d'un travailleur
social
échanger sur leurs véhicules les
difficultés rencontrées au quotidien
essayez de trouver ensemble des
solutions mais infidèle merci maroni
grâce au café des aidants des bénéfices
ya sorte de l'isolément ils sont
accompagnés par le département via le
gps ap qui leur apportent des
informations et surtout du soutien ce
beau moment convivial permet à chacun
d'être accueillis écoutez et valoriser
donjon sylvie moisan cas elle cela fait
maintenant quatre ans que tu participes
au café des aidants quels conseils
donnerais-tu aux autres et dont tu ne
connaissent pas encore ce dispositif
venez tous si le seul conseil à donner
vous serez bien accueillis où serait
heureuse keira bien merci au revoir gaël
merci
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur les cafés les aidants
n'hésitez pas vous avez toutes les
coordonnées qui s'affiche sur votre
écran le département des générations
c'était fini si vous souhaitez vous voir
cet épisode ainsi pelé d'épisodes
précédents rendez vous sur nos sites et
non réseaux sociaux quant à moi je me
retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine je vous amène sur
le terrain de mu et xavier un
agriculteur qui a bénéficié de l'aide
pour l'installation d'un réservoir d'eau
des exploitations agricoles joli coup de
pouce de la part du département pour
accéder à un outil très pratique
[Musique]